346 people
lost their lives in two fatal crashes of
boeing's 737 max airliner in the last
two years
but the nightmare didn't end there the
crash has triggered a hailstorm of
investigations
ousted executives and costs boeing some
20
billion dollars after more than one and
a half years on the ground
the 737 max could now take off again
hundreds of people lost their lives in
two separate boeing
737 max crashes just months apart
that led to the grounding of the model's
entire fleet in march 2019
but now it looks like the planes could
soon be airborne in the u.s again
the country's federal aviation
administration is expected to lift its
grounding order on wednesday
the faa and i in particular will not
approve the plane for return to
passenger service
until i'm satisfied that we've
adequately addressed
all of the known safety issues that
played a role
in the tragic loss of 346 lives
the regulator in boeing were found to
have made a horrific culmination of
failures that led to the crashes
a recent investigation in the us found
fault with boeing's engineers
a lack of transparency in company
management and grossly insufficient
oversight by the faa
the aircraft will still rely on software
linked the two crashes but the regulator
is demanding new training
to handle it inspectors will check the
jets in person
before a flight certificate is granted
the first flights could be as early as
this year
american airlines has planned a 737 max
flight from new york to miami over
christmas
boeing will certainly welcome the news
if he gets the go-ahead but amid a sharp
drop in demand during the pandemic
and new european tariffs getting the
fleet ready
might be a scramble